hello welcome one welcome all to the
fourth annual year reviewers movie
awards I'm one of your hosts Jeremy
Johnson as you may have noticed we're
taking things back to basics this year
which is pretty much code for that's
what our budget allowed us but like any
gift created on the school yard with
construction paper it all comes from the
heart so I want to introduce my other
host and good pals Christian and Mark
from schmoes know guys how's it going
over in schmoeville Thank You Jeremy and
yes it is awesome to be back doing the
you viewers once again are you looking
very there you read it very stylish
today buddy well I don't want to go
stampers last year because that tie
really hurt my neck thank God I have to
wear that every day you got a little
like Sherlock Holmes thing going on I'm
of course your Watson so let's get to
that you reviews Awards for 2014 30
happy very very very happy to do so this
year we have best script starting it out
for a part one and who better to do that
than our buddies over pretty much it
Eric stripped learn the game take it
away howdy folks I'm Eric hey I'm Jake
and I'm Jake's pop Mike oh we're pretty
much it we have the winner of best
script for the 2014 year reviewers
Awards s guy who screen wrote yeah ok
the nominees are were American hustle
the wolf of Wall Street 12 years ago and
before midnight before minute and the
drum roll please
what a cutie her her her is the name of
the film her was a good movie so I was a
great movie and I had this I hope that
this is gonna happen to get the Oscars
because I would love to see some
recognition for the film I am speaking
for my future self cuz I haven't seen it
yet I love it hey thanks for having us
Mo's John's back to you yes yes yes this
is movie I wanted to win best original
script or best script for you reviewers
because her it really touched me
christian in special places that you
don't talk about it made me feel like i
can fall in love with anybody as long as
it's real to me that's all that matters
that's why this has lipstick all over it
I'll be wearing lipstick anyway so yeah
I agree you've heard bye
was by far the best written scrap I'm
glad I won the Oscar I'm glad Ilan the
year viewers great choice very curious
what Jeremy thought about that because
I'm the woman in this relation Jeremy
congratulations to her for winning Best
Screenplay I'm gonna move right along
because they don't have a comment on the
matter because I haven't seen her if you
haven't seen my review of her is because
it doesn't exist because I haven't seen
her even movie reviewers miss movies
every now and then in the year secrets
out so the next category the next
category is best animation to present
that category we have Tom chattel bash
Tom tell us who won what is going on
your viewers community I am pumped to be
back again for the you or viewers movie
awards I can't believe this is the
fourth year I feel so old so I am here
today to present a specific category and
that category is best animated film and
all man - I love those animated films at
this show we have some pretty top-tier
nominees and as for those nominees they
are as follows we have monsters
University the Croods
I completely forgot the other three then
there's Despicable Me 2 epic and of
course frozen and I am about to announce
to you the winner a drumroll please
Christian I hope you add some sort of
drumroll effect when this happens
otherwise it's gonna be very awkward and
the winner is no envelope this year just
gonna say it for rose it gotta say I
love praise I think it's a classic
Disney animated
the omens got great characters great
songs gorgeous animation early harken
back to the at the glory days of Disney
I have to say Disney is something a lot
better than Disney Pixar these days and
frozen was a real home run and I
definitely think you guys made a
fantastic choice I'm choosing that as a
winner and once again as always it is a
distinct pleasure to be presenting at
the you reviewers Movie Awards I love
that we're able to come together and do
this every year as a you reviewers
community it's great to be a part of
this little Avengers like team of movie
reviewers so back to you Kristian and
mark and Jeremy I'm not sure where you
are you seem to change locations every
year you were in a studio one year than
you were in like your respectable
occasions another just back to you and
whatever habitat you are currently
living it now I am not the least bit
surprised about this of course frozen
one frozen was gonna win because
everyone loves frozen who thought frozen
was not gonna win raise your hand that's
not true put your hand down you did not
think frozen was not gonna win you knew
it was gonna win put it down seriously
put it down please do not screw up Idina
Menzel's name no how could you not know
Idina Menzel's mein actually she belted
out let it go and frozen in the hole it
was just clearly the best animation film
this wasn't even close thank you off the
snowmen for some of the best laughs we
got from anyone all year well - John
Travolta's hairpiece let's talk about
the next category and that is the
underrated films there are tons of
underrated films that are out there each
and every year I love the fact that you
reviewers do that and this year
presenting would be a you reviewers
staple at this point the very funny
brett erlich he's that we not underrated
but will under the category anyway take
it away --bread you catch me in these
locations this is the you reviewer award
for most underrated movie of twenty
whatever the last year was I don't know
I was on uppers most of the time you're
next
bigots children's movie next up the way
way back starring that girl from Willy
Wonka and her brand new Oompa Loompas
don't mind if I do but he do also
nominated Rush no not the band or this
movie starring Indian Mark Ruffalo but
rather this film starring his Co Avenger
Thor and that girl from Game of Thrones
who always dressed like a taquito also
nominated the place beyond the pines and
finally the Sundance darling kings of
summer a story of three boys who spend
the summer living in the woods exploring
each other's bodies and learning the
fine line between friendship and lust I
assume we never actually saw this movie
and the winner is rush because this is
America and cars
so congratulations Russian unbe better
than what everyone hussar you believed
you to be I am very happy with that
category I was mad at myself that I
forgot to put that rush in my top ten
last year oh that would have made it huh
oh one hundred percent it's a great
movie I watched it again recently mm-hmm
but no they saw the movie and that was
weird because when it came out I thought
I was gonna be this huge singer ron
howard directing it's about f1 racing
you got chris hemsworth or isn't a
newcomer daniel bruhl giving a great
performance and this that audiences
didn't really go out to see it but it
was a really well-done filming a great
soundtrack glad it won and again well
I'm very curious to see what Jeremy
thought about X I think Jeremy really
liked that movie as well Jeremy alright
rush getting some lives and that's why I
love this award show because rush
deserves some love and rush got some
love here on the you reviewers movie
awards and that makes me a pretty happy
man living in a pretty awesome world the
next category is best hero and to
present best hero is our reviewer from
across the pond bright eyes long lashes
bright eyes take it away Mark Ellis calm
yourself contain
I'm Leah from fright I some lashes and
it is an absolute pleasure to be back
for the you reviewers Awards now this
year I'm presenting the best hero award
so I should probably slip into something
a little bit more appropriate the
nominees are Katniss from The Hunger
Games Catching Fire four from Thor the
dark world and out of Supergirl poses so
Superman from Man of Steel Tony Stark
from Iron Man 3 and Bilbo from the
hobbit the desolation of Smaug and the
winner is Katniss from The Hunger Games
now back to you boys Katniss Everdeen
everyone loves Katniss everyone loves
the Hunger Games you know why everyone
loves Katniss because we share the same
birthday May it's just saying that's I'm
not saying that's why she won I'm saying
it's very cool I feel very cool that I
share a birthday with the best hero of
the year reviewers Movie Awards Katniss
winning it was really cool and I thought
maybe I might be wrong I think this is
the first female to ever win best hero
in the history of the year of yours well
who better than the chick that wins the
Hunger Games I mean she's great early
she's won thus far and I want to give
away any spoilers but again I haven't
read the books everything that I've seen
Jennifer Lawrence through thus far leads
me to believe that she's got to be a
frontrunner for any sort of kick-ass
category in the future
glad to invest here oh boy without heat
without villains can't have heroes well
maybe you can't have you this is true so
let's do best villain and to present
this year is Travis Ross Travis who we
got from best villain
hi my name is Travis Andre rossman
presenting best filming for the 2014
year abuse award show and the nominees
are Michael Fassbender 12 years of slave
Loki Thor the dark world con star trek
into darkness General Zod Man of Steel
and smog from the hobbit the desolation
of smaug and the winner is Michael
Fassbender 12 years of slave
congratulations
you're a phenomenal actor but if you
want to see a real villain watch Woody
Harrelson out of the furnace until next
time enjoy the rest
I look it this was a tough race between
nothing it was it was fast better and
then benedict cumberbatch against
himself twice he he'd made me split the
vote between himself and then michael
fassbender from fogers this lady just
walks into the wind and it was just such
a despicable evil guy in a movie filled
with a lot of really evil white people
he was the leader of them yeah and you
just went to a play so it's just
despicable and it did wasn't that
traditional storybook comic-book villain
this is a dude this was a real person
that sucked at life you know Fassbender
reportedly passed that after seeing
stills of him like bailey's because he
was just so emotionally moved jeremy
don't pass out on us now buddy what do
you think yeah you bet Michael
Fassbender one from 12 years of slave
look I love the batch I love the dragon
I love smile coolest scene in most
movies I saw last year but honestly
nothing made me cringe more than Michael
Fassbender in 12 years of slave
great win dude for our next category
what is a movie without the delicious
musical score to accompany and next we
have best soundtrack slash score slash
music that goes along with the movie
here to present that category is the
crew from one of us dotnet guys show us
what we got that's kiss score yeah score
anyway I'm Christopher Lawrence cuts and
I'm Brian Salisbury believe it or not
and we are from the website one of us
dotnet we're more than pleased to be
here with you guys it's Mo's no talk
about who won this category but first
let's take a look at the nominees and
the nominees are on this list American
hustle woohoo
Man of Steel ha gravity her and inside
Llewyn Davis and now it's outside and
the winner is and we're about to boy
the winner is made of steel that's his
hands of us yeah he's the go-to for
superheroes I mean that was a big fan of
movie but you know great scores on
Zimmer although they all do kind of
sound a little similar I guess anyway
thanks a lot for joining us and now I'm
excited to see what the next category is
back to you guys
Man of Steel alright I love me the hans
zimmer I love the theme song which was
also when the trailer came think of
another song in the entire movie to save
my life but I'm just saying that's what
one that's what got the votes boom don't
know yeah I would've gotten sing it if
you were doing it yes oh man come on
that I like the Hans Zimmer score I'm
glad Man of Steel's score got one
because maybe look was it the John
Williams score no no what Hans Zimmer
did with this car that was great I think
it's a it's a must listen it was fun I
think it was easier to win this category
than it wants to follow anything that
John Williams does so again enjoy are
you reviewers let's let's make sure we
get a cool score when Batman Superman me
in a couple years well let's let's make
sure that we get a couple cool
nominations which we do for supporting
actress and presenting those nominees
would be Jonathan Paula from movie night
hi I'm Jonathan Paula for those who
don't know me I produce a number of web
shows here on YouTube including the
world according to John gametime and is
it a good idea to microwave this
of course I'm most passionate about
movies each week on movie night i
showcase three scripted film reviews
some viewer comments graphics film
footage and some fun sketches if you get
time to check it out I would really
appreciate it
tonight though I have the privilege of
presenting the award for best supporting
actress and here are the nominees
Jennifer Lawrence an American hustle
Lupita Nyong'o for 12 years a slave
margot robbie in the wolf of wallstreet
Julia Roberts in August Osage County and
June Squibb for Nebraska and that you
reviewer award goes to Lupita Nyong'o
now if I'm a luxury at a minute on the
work newcomer Lupita has done despite
having limited screen time she really
impresses in her feature film debut
playing a beaten-down slave with poise
and determination hopefully we'll see
much more of her in the future well that
does it for my segment now back to you
guys in the studio you know well Lupita
Nyong'o not only deserves this award
also the Oscars and how great was her
Oscar speech I can't wait to see her you
reviewer speech she also deserved to get
my lines and non-stop but that's not
what you're celebrating we're
celebrating all like quality that movie
she's like I'm good just being the third
flight attendant but she wins EU
reviewers word here
she wins the best Oscar Jeremy let's
talk a little bit about Lupita and then
Best Supporting Actor Lupita nyong know
that that girl has a career ahead of her
I'm telling you she won an Oscar she
wanted more prestigious you reviewers
movie award I'm just saying I'm just
it's years we're gonna see her for many
many years she was awesome in 12 years
of slave the next category is Best
Supporting Actor and to present that
category is the crew from what the flick
guys let's see it
hello everybody
we're from what the flick I'm Alonso to
reality Christy Lemire mad atcha Dee Ben
mankiewicz and we're here to announce
the winners of a Best Supporting Actor
and the nominees are Jonah Hill for wolf
of wallstreet Michael Fassbender for 12
years of slave a Jared Leto from Dallas
buyers club barkhad Abdi from Captain
Phillips and Daniel Bruhl from Rush and
Alonso the winner dates Jonah Hill from
the wolf of Wall Street's so
congratulations thanks for watching it's
moments like this where we see Jonah
Hill us more than just the fat bet
influenced kid from super bad he's now
the less fat bad influenced guy from
capital America that ain't a bad step
Christian your movie wolf of Wall Street
he's always starting to clean up here
and Jonah Hill was fantastic as the kind
of sidekick kind of a fall guy for Leo's
character I think he won just because of
his teeth um I mean he was incredible
and his accent was great and I like the
fact that he won and it wasn't the
traditional win here and it just shows
that I thought this this really came
from that the fans point of view here
the more of like well this person
deserved is because they've been in
there just a little bit longer
yeah and Jonah Hill proved that he could
do drama with Moneyball but he's my
primary known as a comedic actor and you
got to incorporate both of those in this
performance rule for Wall Street but his
comedy roots might start to show through
when we talk about this next category
which is best comedy I wouldn't I know
your time and I was gonna go into best
comedy here you know best comedy that's
what we got this is a very specific
category that I believe the Oscars to do
as well yes best comedy this year the
intro will be from master debaters
perfect comedy named Michael truly from
Cinna fix
I'm Michael truly from Cinna fix and
we're presenting the best comedy and the
choices are the world's end this is the
end wolf of wallstreet anchorman 2 and
bad grandpa and the winner is I'm gonna
wait an appropriate time to build
suspense which is right about now the
World's End a smart capable Comedy Jam
packs for the details upon second
watching it's fun and I love it back to
you guys okay so the world's end taking
Best Comedy edging out this is the end
yet to apocalyptic kind of funny films
and I guess the world's end maybe Simon
Pegg Nick Frost Edgar Wright maybe they
pushed the time in their favor I'm
shocked at the worlds in one I thought
maybe this is the end would win I even
wolf of wallstreet at one point was I
think attention your movie can't win
everything thing if that should be the
world's and I'm glad one who's a really
funny movie yeah a shock over all that
first that
yeah I'm just very shocked that people
pick this one as the either way I'm
shocked you don't suck thank you well
that's not yet what is this is the end
of part 1 of the you reviewers awards
and thank you everyone out there who has
checked out so far but this isn't our
challenge no it's not right for us to
sing tonight the guy who knows how to
dress himself - the guy punches the
camera and guys that will conclude part
one of two of the you reviewers movie
awards thank you so much for watching
this will be the 1 on my channel part 2
will be on the schmoes node channel be
sure to watch them subscribe to them I
believe we're having a live chat after
part two but Christian from schmoes know
knows more about that I'm I am but a
humble passenger with a suit and tie
that's it but thank you again for
watching we love doing this with you
guys we love doing this for you guys a
lot more to come and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more